how are your Albert I'm doing good reg
thanks for reading
is this your gig now are you doing the
Monday column for the MQB no yeah
terribly um you know I know you know I
well one side of it world you know
trying to respect everything that
everybody loves coming to Peter fool and
on the other side of it you know trying
to make it a little bit different and
you know and and not just lift every
single idea from him so and so you know
it's gonna be it's gonna be evolving
over the next few weeks I know that and
you know it's I've gotten a good
response so far and yeah yeah I mean
it's exciting it's exciting I you know I
I I'd be lying if I didn't tell you I
saw a little bit of pressure last in
doing it sure just because it's you know
I mean and Peters had that slot as far
as um you know I give whatever it is a
half hour every Monday morning for me
for the last 20 years you know and so
there's great responsibilities there
sure
well then congrats in advance and
certainly a great read this morning
Albert how close how realistic was this
Gronkowski trade rumor on Friday best
you can tell not realistic at all
I I don't think it yeah I don't think it
was unrealistic earlier in the offseason
and I think there was a time when this
was all gonna happen when there was a
good possibility I mean if the right
team had come along the Bill Belichick
would have seriously considered it now
you know of course there's the other
piece that which is running it by
ownership and all that different stuff
but I think there was a point where you
know they'd realize that they kind of
come to the feeling that maybe the
statements in the fire off the field the
injuries the way he's just handled
different plan on the roster I think
came up you know they felt like you know
the level of maintenance that it took to
get the production out of him it may
become to the point where they could get
more for him in a trade and I think the
breaking point for all this
Chris you remember what that bizarre
press conference before the month
monster truck rally yeah yeah the
monster and it was in it was in
Foxborough right and it looked like he
was he was having so much fun with it it
looked like he was making fun of the
teammates who were actually doing their
job so yes in a weird way in a weird way
that I think you know that you know my
feeling on it that's what broke the ice
you know that's what we're you know they
finally were able to say okay like let's
bring him in and let but let's let's sit
down let's talk about this and you know
Bill and grog had a conversation at that
point and my understanding at least is
that that's what Gronk sort of affirmed
a bill I want to be here which was an
open question at that point you know
some of the stuff we've seen in social
media obviously the connection Alex
career all that stuff was swirling
around and that was why they you know I
said a what a bit once we had that after
that weird press conference where things
kind of came to a head you know I do
think the air was cleared I used to sell
likely get a contract done before the
season begins and the I think I'll be in
doing a patriot and we probably our pre
are here on the Rich Eisen show up I
don't know if your your cheek is
pressing up against your phone but it's
cutting a little bit in and out and I
want to make sure that I hear what I've
about to get an answer from hear from
you on Earl Thomas this is this is the
one guy that might pull a camp
Chancellor here who would actually tap
this into the season best I can already
hear would you agree yes yes I would
agree with that I think really
penalizing any guy who carries carry to
hold out deep into August and into a
season we've seen less and less and less
of this you know and and and camp chants
who is willing to stick his neck out
actually I mean maybe the only guys it's
a new CBA started asking this game's
over over a contractual dispute and I
just tell you guys the Seahawks are
taking all promises threat very serious
it doesn't mean
to break the bank to keep him or to
bring the door to get him back in the
building
but every indication I get is literal
promises very serious about this Emily
should be I mean this is probably his
last chance at a big payday he turns 30
next year he's been a leap planner for a
long time he's got a pretty extensive
injury history he's played through a lot
of stuff and you know in these
situations I always think that it proves
a player to try to get you know every
piece of financial returns they possibly
can you know we saw it Dez Bryant
recently what what happens to players
when they sort of you know to turn the
corner and and head on to the back nine
of a career and so it's hard to blame
Earl for you know for for seeing things
that way and I certainly think that he's
one of these players who thinks a little
bit differently and probably would have
the resolve to go through so one of the
big stories going into the final
mandatory OTAs before the big six seven
week break Albert yeah I think right
there and right there in Los Angeles I
think Aaron Donald's a huge story you
know I think the what happens with Aaron
Donald and the Rams going forward you
know he showed a willingness to sit out
well on the camp last year
my sense is he's willing to go there
again a lot of optimism around the Rams
but they've got to be pieces in there
and they got they're gonna have some
contractual situations to take care of
over the course of you know the next few
months I talked early could get paid
Brandon cooks is going into a contract
year you know and then of course intern
Donald's the big one and so are they
willing to change the defense's that the
market for defensive players you know
it's scoring Aaron Donald because I
think that's what it's going to take to
get it done and the interesting thing
about that which is that you see Matt
Ryan got his 30 million per right so
Matt bad bet that when that happened
quarterbacks hit 30 million dollars per
year before anyone or any other player
hit twenty million four years that's how
big the gap is between quarterbacks and
everybody else so Kinnear and Donald
closed that gap for that matter can coil
that close that gap he's another one who
it doesn't look like he's going to be a
mini camp this week either and so you
know this time of year you know
see too many significant things outside
of the freak injury so you know really
to me between now and the beginning of
camp you've got the Burling contract
situations with aaron donald cool mac
Le'Veon Bell something more obviously be
talking about ahead of that franchise
deadline next month as well you know
I've been mentioning this of Albert
Priya here in the Rich Eisen show I've
been mentioning this for several weeks
now that there's an iceberg in
Pittsburgh and we only see the very top
of it
there the tip of the iceberg is all we
see and that is Ben Roethlisberger and
Antonio Brown and levy on bail all with
their peccadilloes that Mike Tomlin must
deal with behind the scenes Allah I
guess whatever Steve Kerr was dealing
with with the Warriors this year in a
way yeah you know and so Ben still is a
first-ballot hall-of-famer that's not
gonna be threatened for his job this
year no matter whatever comments he
makes Antonio Brown might Instagram this
or Facebook that that can be handled in
certain ways Le'Veon Bell wants to get
paid in a big big huge way how in the
world did this do how does this finally
work out Albert how does this work with
him I think you know I think operated
for a long time one of the one of the
things that's been so important about
having coaches like Bill Cowher Mike
Tomlin they're over the course of the
last you now almost thirty years is that
those two guys have been so good at
handling and managing personalities and
what that's a lot of Kevin Kohlberg the
personnel department to do is say you
know what you may not take this guy or
this guy or this guy but we're willing
to bring them in because we can work
with those types of players they've
always been able to do that and and
you're right you wonder if there's ever
gonna come a point where you're at that
critical mass just don't pay levy on
abilities on the franchise tag for a
second straight year how will that
affect the way that he handles himself
in the building Antonio Brown global
difference in his contract speaking
caring but certainly you know certainly
that's something where you know you
watch in a week to week basis how he's
handling his business how does that
affect the younger players and then of
course the big one would be in lossless
Berger he's got two years left on his
deal
so there's been office burger ask for
cousins type of contract the interesting
thing there is that the Steelers buy
policy don't give fully guarantee
dollars on their deals they don't do it
because the funding role and so do they
break protocol with Ben Roethlisberger
to try to get his deal done and haven't
how then will that affect other guys
like Brown Mike Bell may not have
guaranteed money on both wheels of snow
you sure there's a lot there like you
said I think the way the Steelers have
always handled it they've always had
these coaches who've been able to handle
big personalities which has allowed them
to kind of cast a wider net as far as
bringing talent in the building and
certainly my Poppa fall in that regard
this fall and last one for do we see
luck throw this week what do you think I
don't think he throws this week I think
you know look I just you know everything
I've heard out of there they're
confident that he's going to be throwing
in the middle at summers beginning a
training camp I would not blame anybody
for being skeptical about this we've
heard this date for him to throw push
back so many times now I think I counted
for setbacks you know between last
summer and fall
I had heard coming out of the season
like that you know again in late January
early February that obviously didn't
happen I don't blame them for exhibiting
caution here is the right way to handle
it but I I would not blame anyone for
being skeptical just because we've seen
the day for him to come back and SPRO
push back so many times um you know
certainly deserves a lot of our
attention there in the middle of July
but but but I don't think we'll see him
throw throw the football this week all
right you coming out here for training
camps you can do it that's right point
yeah yeah we'll be out there we got to
stop by here Albert because I know that
you know that you know you last time
you're here you were tanned and it's a
nice it's a nice uh what is that I think
it's my Instagram I think yeah that was
a good one I add a you know so as you
know I start working on the tin and then
tuck it training can't put it over the
top because I'm outside so Albert
thanks for the call
great read and and hope that's gonna be
a regular gig
alright thanks I appreciate you got a
salver Brad Albert rerun Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience